Minnesota explodes after an incidence of
police brutality ends in death Twitter
mobs search for new targets in their
quest to stamp out racism and President
Trump has an executive order to curb
Twitter I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show today's Ben Shapiro show is
sponsored by Express at VPN your online
activity should not be public protect
yourself and express VPN calm slash Ben
well get to all of the latest breaking
news in just a moment including the
burning of Minneapolis Minneapolis is on
fire last night and this morning we'll
talk about that momentarily first let's
talk about the fact that 40 million
Americans have now lost their jobs from
the economic fallout of coronavirus and
the government induced lockdowns which
it seems like we're over the top we just
don't know what's happening next and you
don't one thing you do know is the
government is gonna spend too much money
and then gonna have to repay that money
either through taxation or inflation it
might be a good time staffers fine two
precious metals in fact if you've done
that a few months ago you'd be sitting
pretty right now this is why you should
have talked to Birch gold when I told
you two months ago go talk to Birch gold
right now one of the things that they
can do for you is if you're interested
convert your traditional IRA or 401k
into a precious metals IRA whether you
decide to do that or not it is
worthwhile to at least have part of your
portfolio in precious metals it hedges
against inflation against uncertainty
against the vicissitudes of a government
that is willing to spend money that has
not yet been created before May 31st
with a qualifying purchase Birch gold
we'll give you a free emergency kit is
the last time you get the offer so hurry
the backpack is absolutely loaded with
everything you can't buy right now so
safeguard your savings with Birch gold
they'll help safeguard your family like
they have many many many others like
tens of thousands of others including my
own there's no obligation you have
nothing to lose to take that first step
go check out Birch gold group a plus
rating from the Better Business Bureau
don't wait for the market to continue to
bounce around before you at least hedge
against that bouncing go check them out
and get your free emergency kit by
texting Ben's who 47 47 47 and
diversifying today again text Ben to 47
47 47 text Ben's 47 47 47 okay so
obviously the big story of the day is
the looting and burning in Minnesota and
that follows hard on what is another
video of an awful incident involving the
police and I think that once more it is
important to recognize that everyone
should be on the same side of this I
really everyone should be on the same
side of this what we have seen
we're not what we've seen here is a
police officer kneeling on the neck of a
black man for four straight minutes
while he's being told by people
including the guy who was underneath his
knee that he cannot breathe okay it's
really really ugly and it's really
really bad what is not clear is whether
it is really really racial now the
implication by the media is always that
it is race driven because whenever there
is a white officer doing something bad
to a black suspect the implication is
that it is race driven but here's the
reality police officers generally do a
very good job there are some police
officers who are terrible at their jobs
and jackasses and treat everybody
horribly we have not yet seen evidence
that this police officer is a racist as
we will see people who are trying to
manufacture evidence of that yesterday
but this thing has been handled the way
it's supposed to be handled these
officers probably will end up standing
trial we don't yet have a medical
examiner's report so this is part of the
problem when you are going to put
somebody on trial for say negligent
homicide for manslaughter or for murder
or for something like that you actually
have to determine cause of death so in
the Eric garner case in New York to
which this is being compared in that
particular case Eric garner didn't
actually die of the quote/unquote
chokehold that he was put in he died
because you know he had an underlying
heart condition he died of a heart
attack that was sort of attendant on the
the incident itself and so that led to
sort of complications in a lot of the
investigation it is not clear at this
point that this person died because he
had a knee on the back of his neck and
the very least the officer should go to
jail for assault you would assume
because this is not within the purview
of employment you don't get just to his
police brutality obviously okay so
here's a little bit of the video and
there at the video for people who can't
actually watch so the original story
from the officers is that this man whose
name is George Floyd they were called on
the they were called because he was
engaging in some sort of forgery he's
forging checks or something in his car
and they showed up and the original
narratives that he had resisted arrest
the tape doesn't appear to show him
resisting arrest
in any real way here's a little bit of
the tape so you can see that he is he's
taken out of the car is very large man
taken out of the car by this white
officer he doesn't appear to be
resisting arrest anywhere here and at a
certain point the officer he kind of
falls to the ground and I guess this is
where you would quote/unquote say that
he's resisting but
the officer is kneeling on his neck and
just putting his foot putting his knee
on his neck
and he's saying he can't breathe the
guy's saying he can't breathe and people
around the office are saying you need to
get up off the guy can't breathe I mean
it's just egregious it's egregious
egregious of Regis and he should be
prosecuted this officer to the fullest
extent of the law into which the
evidence shows and by the way everyone
agrees with this everyone agrees with us
right there is there is no dissent on
this particular point from the
Minneapolis Mayor to civil rights
leaders to President Trump to the
militant Minneapolis Police Department
everybody's office all four officers who
were present here
yeah the officer who did the kneeling
and the officers who are standing around
him all of them had been fired like
immediately not put on suspension not
put on leave fire it out right which
means by the way a prosecution is coming
down the pike and other law enforcement
officials are pointing out that this is
insane according to The Wall Street
Journal Floyd's death in custody draws
condemnation from law enforcement
officials so according to law
enforcement officials the FBI the
Minnesota Bureau of Criminal
Apprehension they said they are
investigating the incident
president Trump tweeted late on
Wednesday that he'd asked the FBI and
the Justice Department to expedite the
investigation into Floyd's death he said
my heart goes out to George's family and
friends justice will be served President
Trump himself came out he said we're
gonna get a full report one into a full
investigation the here's President Trump
yesterday talking about this
look at it
okay obviously the president does he
look like he is celebrating racism in
this particular clip Minneapolis Mayor
Jacob fry originally called for charges
to be bought brought against the
arresting officer he said that we we
should see some sort of prosecution in
short order he'd like to see a
prosecution in short order the head of
the Minneapolis Police Union Bob Kroll
stirred controversy when he wore cops
for Trump t-shirts with Trump rally in
the city and sold them as a fundraiser
after Fry said that the president wasn't
welcome but that has really nothing to
do with anything that has happened here
Houston police chief art acevedo who's
president of an organization that
represents police chiefs from America's
larger cities said it was unfathomable
for an officer to put a knee into a
handcuffed suspect neck as the video
showed Acevedo said I haven't heard
anybody justify this the head of the
major city chiefs Association said he
couldn't recall such uniform
condemnation of an officer's action by
other police ever occurring in the past
the arresting officer has been
identified as one Derek Shelvin by his
lawyer Tom Kelly who declined further
comments police are trained to pin down
suspects by putting their knee on the
shoulder blade not the neck unless
deadly force is justified according to
miami-dade police chief Juan Perez the
FBI has declined to comment so far to
bring the federal civil rights case the
Justice Department has to reach a
difficult standard of proof they have to
show that the officer not only acted
with excessive force but also willfully
violated someone's constitutional rights
that's it that's a big lift but local
law enforcement no local law does not
necessarily have that lift the bottom
line is this there is unanimity on this
right unanimity the mayor of Minneapolis
is saying the officers should be charged
the officers have been laid off the DA's
are going to investigate the FBI's gonna
investigate DOJ is gonna investigate
police shoots all around the country are
condemning this and the only sort of
outstanding question right now is why
exactly Floyd died because the the
medical report is inconclusive at this
point the medical report says that the
cause and manner of death is currently
pending further testing an investigation
by the Hennepin County Medical
Examiner's Office and that will clear up
what exactly the charges should be here
so this should be a situation where
there is not actually a lot of
controversy and yet controversy has
arisen the reason there shouldn't be
controversies because we're all reacting
the same way except when it comes to the
question of race and the question of
race has become obviously the focal
point here with people immediately
jumping - not only was the answer
racist not only is Derrick Shelvin
racist but also all of America is racist
and you saw a lot of tweets like this
yesterday all of America is doing this
to black people this is where the
conversation starts to break down pretty
quickly because you are leaping beyond
the evidence of the incidents to make
two conclusions one that the incident
was driven primarily by racism or even
secondarily by racism and two that all
of America is responsible if indeed even
if this officer was a vicious racist who
decided to kill a black man that day by
putting his knee on the guy's neck how
that indicates all of America is beyond
me
I just don't I don't see it we're all
condemning it like it's hard to pin a
evil act on everyone in America or on
America more broadly when everyone is
condemning the action I've yet to see a
person defending the action of the
officer okay so we'll get to that in
just one second how this becomes
politicized we'll get to that
momentarily first let's talk about the
fact that you can get a great gift for
your dad this Father's Day Greg if your
parents have been able to see your
parents in a while if they are in their
60s or above thanks to all of lockdowns
if you want to get somebody a truly
meaningful gift I mean like the most
meaningful gift you can get them what
you need to do is make sure that their
memories are preserved this is a super
important thing this is why you should
check out legacy box legacy box is a
super simple mail and service you have
all your home movies and pictures
digitally preserved on the thumb drive
DVD or the cloud
don't let priceless family memories
disappear that's what happens if you
don't take action instead here's an idea
do you have home projects that you've
been putting off you know you have that
garage that's full of old film reels and
you don't have a film projector get all
the old VHS tapes they you took off the
camcorder and now you no longer have a
VCR why not get all of that digitally
preserved by the great folks over at
legacy box I really I know the people
who started the company they started in
a garage they are awesome great
Americans doing an amazing job of
preserving people's memories they care
for your memories the way they would
their own legacy boxes the world's
largest digitizer of home movies and
photos they've helped over
three-quarters of a million families
digitally preserve their past the
process is really easy start to finish
you pack and you send their team
digitized everything by hand to brighten
your day legacy box is currently
offering an incredible 40% off buy today
to take advantage of this exclusive
offer and then send in when you're ready
go to legacy box calm /ban say 40% while
supplies last that his legacy box calm
/then okay so this became quickly
politicized even though it didn't have
to be politicized
because people decided to make claims
that are simply beyond what the facts
demonstrate and then because they are
making those claims they have decided to
justify the rioting that is going on in
Minnesota this is so counterproductive
it's beyond belief if you believe that
protests are legitimate against police
brutality why in the world would you
start justifying riots like people
looting targets and such it's beyond
insane but it ties into the again
broader American narrative that target
is somehow is guilty of this thing
because target is part of America as you
are guilty as the officer is guilty so
Joe Biden yesterday suggests that the
black community in America is under
threat now that is just not true
I'm sorry it's not true I don't know I
should have to apologize and it's a good
thing it's a very good thing the black
community in America is not under threat
there is this narrative that Joe Biden
has been attempting to drive pointed
this out last week when Joe Biden was
saying that you can't be legitimately
black if you vote for a Republican the
implication that he was drawing which is
a nasty and horrible and ugly
implication is that Republicans are
seeking to exterminate black people
which is just disgusting and horrifying
in every possible way it is free of
evidence it is gross but it ties it into
a broader narrative that America is just
as racist as it has always been america
is the land of slavery and Jim Crow
nothing has changed black people in
America are under existential threat
here was Joe Biden suggesting that black
Americans are under existential threat
each and every day it's not true by
statistics it is not true I can't
breathe
is a tragic reminder that this was not
an isolated incident but a part of an
ingrained systemic cycle of injustice it
still exists in this country it cuts at
the very heart of our sacred belief that
all Americans are equal and rights and
indignity and it sends a very clear
message to the black community and black
lives that are under threat every single
day okay black lives are not under
threat every single day from America
writ broad or police writ broadly by the
way statistical studies continue to show
over and over and over like repeatedly
that there is no disproportionate
shooting of black men by white officers
in America this is not a statistical
reality that does not mean that black
people aren't mistreated by police that
doesn't mean that there aren't racist
police officers who do bad things of
course all of that is true
but if we are going to act if we are
going to actively accuse the entire
United States a victim
black people to the extent that black
lives are always in danger wherever you
go and travel around America and you
will see that this is not actually the
case you know a huge percentage of
Americans are black and the vast ssssss
majority nearly all of them are not
under threat of killing every single day
that's it's such a wild overstatement
and it's a wild overstatement that has a
political purpose and the purpose is to
suggest that only Joe Biden and
Democrats can protect you but the
reality is that your fellow Americans if
you are black are not seeking to kill
you this is not a this is not a reality
there's a study that was published in
August of 2019 in the Proceedings of the
National Academy of Sciences and it
showed that the police are not
disproportionately shooting black men
what dictates who gets shot by the
police is the rate of violent crime in a
community the more frequently officers
encounter violent suspects from any
given racial group the greater the
chances that members of that group will
be shot by a police officer so if you
are a police officer and you're in a
high crime Hispanic neighborhood it is
more likely you're going to shoot a
Hispanic male if you are in a high crime
white neighborhood it is more likely
you're going to shoot a white male black
civilians are actually shot less
compared to whites then their rates of
violent crime would predict that's
according to one study then there was a
study by Roland fryer who is a black
socio sociologist who studies crime over
at Harvard University he found that
conditional on police interaction there
are no racial differences in officer
instigated shootings on either the
extensive or intensive margins after
controlling for suspect demographics
officer demographics encounter
characteristics suspect weapon and year
fixed effects blacks are twenty-seven
point four percent less likely to be
shot by police then relative to non
black and non-hispanics investigating
the intensive margin who shoots first
and an encounter with police or how many
bullets were discharged from the
endeavor there are no detectable racial
differences according to Roland fryer
again a black professor from Harvard
University so the narrative that black
Americans are under threat from police
broadly speaking across America is just
not true it's not a reality that does
not mean that there aren't more
confrontations between black Americans
and police because police are usually in
high crime neighborhoods and
unfortunately there are a lot of high
crime neighborhoods that happen to be
black that is that's that's a tragedy
and it's and the only way that's why we
saw this with more police not fewer
police is with crime rates going down
now crime rates going up but the gen
lies narrative that America is broadly
guilty for the actions of Derek Shelvin
or even by the way that Jarek Shelvin is
is an unrepentant racist and that's why
this happened is it's a bizarre take and
people are stretching the truth to get
there so take for example Ice Cube
alright so Ice Cube tweeted out the
rapper Ice Cube the actor Ice Cube he
tweeted out yesterday a picture of Tareq
Shelvin with his knee on this guy's neck
and then a picture of another guy
wearing a make White's great again look
it looks like a maggot at right it's red
with the white text says make White's
great again they writes a wolf in wolves
clothing the demons are among us
hashtag fight the cowards and um there's
only one problem with this and the one
problem with this is that the person in
the right hand side of the photo is not
the person in the left hand side of the
photo it's just not true according to
snopes.com this is this is not the right
person right the person who is actually
wearing that hat and this this witness
made the rounds yesterday it was
trending on Twitter because the idea was
this was an unrepentant racist who had
killed a black man because he was a
racist and also a trump supporter
presumably because of a hat it turns out
that the photo actually chose a guy
named Jonathan Rich's a supporter of
President Trump who's also a former
federal inmate and an online troll who's
garnered a reputation for filing
lawsuits okay so so they just this was
taken and it was and it was placed next
to the photo to demonstrate that this
was obviously an instance of racism
again maybe it is and maybe it isn't
we're gonna have to find out the
evidence on this but even if it is that
does not indicate broad-based American
racism then Ice Cube tweeted back
tweeted out how long will we go for blue
on black crime before we strike back
strike back against him against the
police officers didn't who didn't do
this I mean is he calling for violence
against police officers how is any of
this useful how is any of this good
Gayle King on CBS Morning News she said
the same thing she said well this seems
like open season on black men again
where is the evidence that it is open
season on black men where's the evidence
I understand why you would look at a
video and think that's a really ugly
incident and it's a white guy and two
black guy and obviously that is an
instance of racism I understand why you
might jump to that conclusion but let me
just say you still have to follow the
evidence I mean Gayle King is a reporter
and not only should Gayle King not be
saying
the suggestion that black men everywhere
are in danger from the police is just
like at some point you're going to have
to present prevent present the evidence
for this
well I'm very tired of the illogical
jump between police were racist in 1960
and police are racist in 2020 to the
extent that every black man in America
is in danger like that it's it's it's
divisive it's ugly and the time when
again we're all unified everyone agrees
that this guy's Eric Sheldon should go
to jail I'm waiting to hear the person
who's like yeah that sounds like what he
did seems like good to me like what no
one is saying that here is Gayle King
you know again drawing a conclusion that
is not supportable by the evidence we go
from that story now to this story where
she falsely accused as a black man on
television I mean III don't even know
what to do or how to handle this at this
particular time I know that this is I'm
speechless
I'm really really speechless about what
we're seeing on television this morning
it feels to me like a open season and
that it's just not sometimes a safe
place to be in this country for black
men and today is too much for me okay it
is yes America is a safe country for
black men it is a very very safe country
for black men it's a safe country for
nearly everyone crime rates in America
have gone down so dramatically since the
1960s and it makes your head head boggle
I mean since 1994 the crime rates in
America have just have just dropped into
the basement and the Minneapolis mayor
did the same thing he says being black
shouldn't be a death sentence being
black is not a death sentence it is not
a death sentence there are over 30
million black Americans living in the
United States it is not a death sentence
to be black in America can we please
stop with this sort of rhetoric there's
a point in which it was in fact a
sentence to living death to be black in
America when slavery was a thing there
was a point when it was it was to be
sentenced to second-class citizenship to
be black in America it's when Jim Crow
is a thing
it is not a death sentence to be black
in America today and if you think that
it is you're delusional you're
delusional
either that or you're allowing your
passion to overcome your reason here's
the Minneapolis Mayor making a claim
that is completely unsupportable by
evidence being black in America should
not be a death sentence for five minutes
we watched as a white officer pressed
his knee into the neck of a black man
for five minutes when you hear someone
calling for help you are supposed to
help this officer failed in the most
basic human sense
okay agree with the passion agree with
the conviction wildly disagree with the
idea that if you're a black man in
America that is a death sentence I mean
that's it that's it that's a wild
statement it's a wild statement that
being black in America's death sentence
how many black people live in
Minneapolis a lot of black people live
in Minneapolis hey is that a death
sentence for all the black people living
in Minneapolis he's the mayor maybe you
should do something about that that
sounds pretty terrible this is this sort
of rhetoric is deeply polarizing for no
reason because again we all agree this
officer should go to jail based on the
available evidence we all agree that he
did something that is disgusting an
egregious no one's defending it but the
jump from that to the already set 16:19
project narrative that America is racist
in every way and everything in America
that's good is fruit of the poisonous
tree and then America continues to be
just as racist it ever was it's really
it's it's bad stuff it's bad stuff is
bad for the country we'll get some more
of this in just one second because it's
actually now being used the sort of
mentality is being used to justify
rioting by and looting by some people or
at least overlooking rioting and looting
what we're supposed to justify the the
anger of people who'll do to target as
though you're honoring George Floyd's
memory by stealing a TV or some such
nonsense
it gives that in just one second first
let's talk about the fact that life is
unpredictable the world is unpredictable
and that means that you should ensure
against that unpredictability you should
get all the types of insurance you need
disability insurance and auto insurance
and life insurance and the best way to
do all of this is to go check out policy
genius because policy genius is the
insurance marketplace online there's big
demand for life insurance right now if
you're looking to get life insurance
here's how policy genius can help policy
genius will compare quotes from the top
life insurance companies in one place it
takes just a few minutes to compare
quotes from the top insurers and find
your best price this doesn't just save a
lot of legwork you could say 1500 bucks
or more a year by using policy genius to
compare life insurance policies once
apply the policy genius team handles all
the paperwork and the red tape for free
they're in contact with life insurance
companies every day monitoring
developments helping customers navigate
every step so if you're one of the many
people looking to buy life insurance
right now but you're not sure where to
start well I have an easy answer for you
head on over to policy genius.com again
that's policy genius.com go check them
out right now over at policy genius.com
get the life insurance and get the auto
insurance get the disability insurance
all the insurance that you could
possibly need go check them out right
now I promise you it's going to be very
very useful okay so there is something
that is deeply Despicable obviously in a
very different way than than what
appears to be the manslaughter and/or
murder of a human being but deeply
despicable politically and and really
bad for the country in suggesting that
when a bad thing happens that that thing
innately demonstrates American racism
and then you don't even have to provide
evidence the allegation is itself the
evidence of the racism right an evidence
of America's broad-based racism even if
America rejects the action itself so
LeBron James did this again LeBron James
has an unfortunate habit of injecting
himself into controversies in ways that
are not well informed now listen I
appreciate that
again LeBron James I think tries to be
politically active that's fine he's
entitled to his opinion that doesn't
mean that he's entitled to be this
deeply wrong so LeBron James he's not
entitled to his own set of facts in
other words LeBron James put up this
thing on his Instagram in which he in
which he compared the the officer Derek
shalva kneeling on the neck of this
George Floyd unfortunate human being and
and Colin Kaepernick kneeling and said
this is why he says do you understand
now or is it still blurred to you
hashtag stay woke well no it's still
blurred to me because Colin Kaepernick
was not kneeling to protest police
brutality alone he was kneeling because
his suggestion is that America tolerates
police brutality that America has Pro
police brutality that America is racist
that the American flag represents racism
and that is nasty and it is garbage and
it is not true and you know who knows
that's not true LeBron James who has
done extraordinarily well in America and
he should because he's an incredibly
talented human being and his color has
not been an obstacle to him being
incredibly successful in the United
States that's a very good thing
Colin Kaepernick's color was not an
obstacle to be him
success in the United States know that
the point was that that was not why
Colin Kapernick was kneeling Colin
Kaepernick was wearing socks with pigs
on them dressed up as cops as though all
cops were pigs the conflation of a bad
cop with racist cop and then that
conflation of racist cop with all of
America is really quite despicable and
again unsupportable by evidence it
divides us in ways that are just
unthinkably bad unthinkably wrong
because the fact is that there are so
many black Americans who have fought for
that flag there are so many black
Americans who serve in police forces
there are so many black Americans who
are law-abiding citizens and so many
black Americans who rightly fight this
kind of stuff in the proper ways that
conflating people who are doing it and
stupid and divisive and nasty ways with
that is just it's completely ridiculous
and silly and you're seeing this sort of
thing arise in Minnesota so in Minnesota
overnight there are a bunch of protests
and protests are fine right
that's the First Amendment right what is
not a First Amendment right is breaking
into the target in looting it I remember
we had the LA riots in in in my home
city live that was 1994 the LA riots I
believe I was ten at the time and I
remember la burning so here's 1992 so I
was eight and it was and it was and
Maxine Waters called it the LA uprising
burning down stores and stealing TVs is
not an uprising it's you being a piece
of crap okay that's not in any way in
any way excusing police brutality I just
I'm wondering how smashing the cash
registers at Target is solving police
brutality exactly how exactly is you
breaking into a target and then
ransacking the shelves solving police
brutality you're burning down an
autozone which is another thing that
happened in Minneapolis last night it's
disgusting I'm sorry looting is
disgusting rioting is discussing and no
it is not justified by this sort of
stuff it is not justified by the general
shavon case protests outside the police
station are justified by all this sort
of stuff but I'll tell you things that
are not justified by this sort of stuff
breaking into the target which is
completely unrelated smashing store
windows there was a tape of two guys who
had gone to their local store in
Minneapolis and they were standing
outside their store with guns saying the
cops have been basically told to stand
down we're not gonna stand down we're
gonna protect our property by the way
they should be protesting the police
these two things are not mutually
exclusive you can very much understand
the protests
the police even though the police by the
way did the right thing and fired these
guys and there will be prosecutions I am
sure but the attempt to excuse rioting
is utterly asinine and you're seeing a
lot of that online right now yeah well
you know the anger is justified the
anger is just you're not stealing TV
because you're angry you're stealing a
TV because you want a TV you burning
down an autozone is not you being angry
you see you burn down an autozone is
because you're a criminal and you feel
like burning down an autozone sorry
that's not the way this works there are
a lot of angry people in American
politics does any of that mean that you
get to go and loot the local grocery
obviously not it's absurdity piled on
absurdity and then you had the the riots
though that wasn't that there was there
was I would call it riot I would suppose
in Los Angeles people attacking cop cars
like full-on attacking cop cars there's
footage of people smashing cop car
windows gathering around cop cars and
attacking police officers who had
nothing to do with this in a completely
different City how anytime you say
things like well you know the anger is
justified the anger is justified I don't
care about whether your feelings are
justified I care mostly about whether
your actions are justified you're first
of all your feelings against eight an
unrelated police officer are probably
not justified once you put it that way
and your feelings against target are
certainly not justified but the attempt
to to to sort of shy away from exposing
bad behavior and to pretend the bad
behavior is not happening here is
insipid and ridiculous on every level
and again very bad for the country
because and bad for the protesters by
the way if you want sympathy for your
protest then you should not unify with
it with the looters and with the riders
and I haven't seen the protesters doing
that by the way by and large I've seen a
lot of people on Twitter trying to
pretend that if you pay attention to the
looting you're a bad person if you pay
attention to the fact that Minneapolis
was in flames last night so much so that
satellites were picking up the smoke
that if you if you pay attention to that
that somehow you're ignoring the
underlying crime that happened but as
always many things can be true at one's
you burning down in autozone makes you a
piece of crap you know what else makes
you a piece of crap even more a piece of
crap kneeling on the neck of a person
until they die that makes you like the
worst piece of crap but among other
pieces of crap who are less bad but also
pieces of crap are people who loot
because they feel like stealing bleep
and people who put up signs on the sides
of buildings while they're burning down
an unrelated building saying F the
police none of this is justified it's
not Kane's who pretends it is and to go
soft on it or to suggest that all of
this is deeply indicative of underlying
American racism and therefore you can
burn down the target because the target
is just part of the giant superstructure
of America and it's supported by
capitalism and it's insured anyway
seriously disgusting truly disgusting
and here's the thing again it doesn't
have to be this way it doesn't none of
this has to be this way we could all
agree on this stuff but we have
deliberately decided that we're not
going to agree on this stuff instead we
are going to read into evidence things
which have not yet been evidenced and as
we will see we're going to carry this
over to even the most minut and stupid
of conflicts at least in this case of
Jarek shavon you could you could see the
jump but in many other cases that are
popping up on Twitter like every two
days now there's an attempt to attribute
to America more broadly into American
history into the deep superstructure of
American racism instances in which
there's no actual evidence of racism
we're just going to we're just going to
destroy people on Twitter now for no
apparent reason we're gonna get to that
in just one second first let's talk
about the fact that you need a VPN right
now you do you're at home you don't have
your IT department able to protect you
you need to make sure that you are
protected how can you do this you need
to Express VPN so expressvpn is better
than other VPNs if you download a free
VPN from the internet the ISP can
actually grab all your data and then
monetize it by selling it to advertisers
also uh the a lot of other VPNs will
slow down your internet connection make
it impossible for you to traffic freely
on the internet expressvpn does not slow
down your internet connection it's very
easy to install it's very easy to use it
runs in the background of your computer
you don't even notice it's there it's
just there like a silent guardian
protecting you each and every day
expressvpn doesn't log your data they've
developed a technology called trusted
server that makes it impossible for
their servers to log any of your data
again their speeds are blazing fast very
easy to install so go protect yourself
today with the VPN I use and trust
myself use my link at expressvpn comm
slash pen today get an extra three
months for free on a one-year package
that's expressive VPN calm and slash pen
again Express
VPN calm slash Ben to learn more that's
expressed VPN dot-com slash Ben go check
it out right now
okay so
the the you can tell a narrative is is
now taking place Minneapolis is leading
the way because that is the worst of
these situations right it ended with a
human beings death a person who never
should have died obviously but we are
also seeing on Twitter a bunch of other
sort of minor confrontations elevated
into major confrontations without
evidence
so here's an example there is an
unfortunate person whose name is Tom
Austin Tom Austin is apparently some
sort of executive and Tom Aston lives in
a private building it has a private
there is some sort of private private
gym at this private building and in
order for you to access the private gym
you are supposed to be you know a member
of the building this exists at many many
many buildings and so this fellow Tom
Austin gets taped by a group of
self-described young black entrepreneurs
okay he gets taped why because he asks
them to see their keycards
and they say no they say that we are we
are from the building and we are not
gonna do this in your racially profiling
us and now there's no evidence that he's
racially profiling them as in none right
I don't know that he routinely asked
people in the gym whether or not they
are supposed to be there or not
also as it turns out some of these guys
actually didn't have key cards
apparently so
this tape is put on Twitter here is
here's the tape it has millions of views
literally millions views almost 6
million views on Twitter here is the
tape of Tom Austin apparently being a
vicious racist at no point does he
mentioned their race and no points does
he say anything racist we know he's a
racist because he asked people in a
private gym whether they ought to be in
the private gym here's Tom Austin he he
personally trended on Twitter last night
I'm Tom Austin I'm a tenant in the
building are you
whatever so we have a office here and
this guy came accusing us we can't be
here as you guys could see we're dealing
with racism here okay so at no point
here is there any implication of racism
nonetheless this guy is forced to go
online and then issue a Mia culpa saying
that he's a part of the white
supremacist infrastructure because how
stupid our world is now what he actually
say he said yes I effed up should have
handled it differently not my job to
have done anything so now we are saying
that he's not allowed to ask anybody if
they're in the private gym improperly or
to call anybody if somebody is in the
private gym improperly because God
forbid they should be of a different
race that means that he's a racist
he's his building management had been
complaining that tenants were allowing
their friends to trespass and use a
private gym as authorized only for
building tenants when I arrived to the
gym I said hello to everyone but after
working out for ten minutes I noticed
that one of the tenants seemed to have
brought four friends and I complains
then this isn't right
one guy was letting his other four
friends in and out of the building with
his own pass card four guys did not have
a pass card when I said something they
got in my face accusing me of racial
profiling I said it wasn't racial
profiling it was all about suspicious
activity behavior because they were in
because they were in my face and didn't
have pass cards I took photos and called
the property manager I only call the
building property manager I didn't call
nine-one-one I told them I'd have done
the same thing if they were white or
even if a bunch of girls were trash
passing but the videos didn't show as I
spent 15 minutes listening to their
grievances I empathize with them the
challenges they faced what surprises me
is that this video was posted even
though we worked out in the gym together
for another 45 minutes while having
friendly banter everyone was fine I'd
already apologized to them for making
them feel it was a racial race issue and
I listened to all their grievances when
I left the gym at the end of the night I
said have a great night hope we're good
did a fist bump with each of them
there's way more to the story I've
offered to reach out and sit down with
the guys nobody has responded seems more
about hyping up the community rather
than trying to come to truth and having
an honest conversation obviously this
guy's a vicious racist and we should end
his career clearly he did something
deeply deeply wrong and we've seen so
many of these in the past week and a
half like an incredible number of these
right we had that clip between the Fed
Ex employees and the homeowner where the
Fed Ex employee suggested the homeowner
did something truly terrible and racist
there was no evidence that any of this
happened so the story sort of
disappeared from the news right there
was no follow-up he
it turns out that no investigation could
show apparently that something deeply
horrible had happened and racist fashion
here these guys got fired from FedEx
after posting the tape
we had a full week of controversy after
two people basically yelled at each
other in Central Park after one man a
black man saw a white woman who is
walking her dog off leash in the bird
watching part of the power can ask her
to put the dog on the leash and she
refused and he said well if you won't do
what I want then I'm gonna do something
that you don't like and then he summoned
her dog over with dog treats even though
I didn't have a dog and she felt
threatened and she said that I'm gonna
call the cops on you and this became a
major racial blow-up hey how is any of
this like solving racism a question how
is any of this helping us solve racism
is that any of this forwarding the
forwarding the cause also it seems like
there's relative unanimity on what good
behavior constitutes and what bad
behavior constitutes except in the media
there's an entire article by woman named
Ruby Hammad called a white damsel
leveraged racial power and failed well
then maybe she didn't have racial power
does that ever occur to anybody if you
leverage power and you fail maybe you
were overestimating your amount of
racial power the viral video of this
tense interaction between a white woman
walking her dog and a black man
bird-watching in Central Park has become
the latest flashpoint not only of
discussions of racism and police
brutality against black men but also of
the pivotal role played by white women
the damsel in distress archetype
probably conjures up images of delicate
maidens and chivalrous gentlemen that's
precisely what it's designed to do for
white people to people of color and
especially african-americans who have
borne the brunt of her power in the
United States the image is very
different so now we are going to compare
this woman who called the cops after a
guy tried to dry out a drop draw her dog
over with treats from his pocket and
said a quasi racist thing that she's
gonna call the cops insane
african-american man is threatening her
and there's no reason to plan trays
there that when she when she does that
this is the same as they as the evil
history in America of white women
claiming the black man had ravished them
and then justifying that could be the Ku
Klux Klan that is the way that we are
going to work here
this is such a - every New York Times
column is here's the thing that happened
in 2020 it's exactly the same as the
thing that happened in 1850 - exactly
we're not gonna explain why it's exactly
the same it's every time he see Coates
column every single one is or every
Jamelle Bouie column
bad thing happening in 2020 remember
when a bad thing happened in like 1920
and it wasn't the same what we're gonna
say it's exactly the same because
history is history has fruit this column
then goes to the the memoir of a woman
named Harriet Jacobs published in 1861
two connects to this this tapestry of
testimonials reveals a social fabric
held together not only by the sexual
abuse of black women but also by the
collective projection of blame back onto
the victims wherever European men
colonized the damsel followed miss
Cooper has been fired from her job
following an outcry if she yanked her
thrashing in yelping cocker spaniel by
the collar has surrendered her dog by
the way I just I don't know dogs well
enough it seems to me that if you leash
a dog and you were pulling the dog
around by the leash it's pretty much the
same thing as holding the dog by the
collar but maybe I'm completely wrong on
all of this
but again the idea here is that she is a
symbol of long lasting white supremacy
except she's the one who got fired did
anything happen to Christian Cooper
except that he got a bunch of wonderful
coverage in the media by the way he said
I'm not excusing the racism I don't know
that her life needed to be torn apart
but then he said he said if we're gonna
make progress we've got to address these
things if this painful progress is going
to help us address this there's a yellow
warbler if this painful process helps to
correct or takes us a step further for
addressing the underlying racial
horrible assumptions that we African
Americans have to deal with an adult
with for centuries that this woman
tapped into then it's worth it sadly it
has to come at her expense so in other
words I'm sorry she lost her job time
now so sorry she lost her job because
racial progress depends on people
blowing up racial incidents or even on
racial incidents as it turns out in some
of these cases into massive indicators
of broad-based American racism wait and
and by the way we're now extending this
conversation into the world of kovat
which is is purely insane because kovat
is a disease people go with disease
we're gonna get some more of this in
just one second then we'll get to
President Trump going after Twitter
first let's talk about the fact that
everybody needs a pair of great wireless
earbuds but before you go dropping
hundreds of bucks on a pair why don't
you spend less and get the same quality
earbuds that fit your ear better I'm
talking about ray cons as you already
know ray con earbuds start at about half
the price of any other premium wireless
you're about on the market they sound
just as amazing as the other top audio
brands that you know their newest model
the everyday II 25-year buds are the
best ones yet six hours of playtime
seemly
bluetooth pairing more bass a more
compact design that gives you that nice
noise-isolating fit rate cons wireless
earbuds are incredibly comfortable
they're perfect for conference calls or
for pinching podcasts unlike some of
your other wireless options rake on
earbuds are both stylish and discreet no
dangling wires no stems to distract
anybody during video calls now is the
time to get the latest and greatest from
retcon one of things I like they're not
one-size-fits-all they've got a bunch of
fits for your ear so it's gonna fit your
ear absolutely perfectly come in a
variety of color so you can look stylish
get 15% off your order at buy rake on
Comm slash man that is bu ir a YCL ENCOM
slash been buy rake on.com slash been
again by rake on Comm slash been and get
15% off the best pair of wireless
earbuds on the market for a lot less buy
break uncommon slash been for 15% off
okay in just one second we will get to a
lot more of the news because there's a
lot going on but first remember the
double tumbler is back that's right but
it is only available for our most
exclusive at memberships here all access
the all access membership tier it's our
premiere two level of membership all
access members get to participate in all
access live that is our brand-new
interactive programming featuring one of
the daily wire hosts as we hang out with
you each and every night all access
members also get to join us for
real-time Q&A discussions available on
both the website and the daily wire app
i'll access membership now includes two
of the irreplaceable left is tears
tumbler two counting to the tumblers are
literally overflowing with tears but
figuratively at the thought of this
particular offer by the way you should
check out our all accesses they are
they're very fun i wear t-shirts and i
sing songs and i do stupid voices and i
answer all the questions you could
possibly imagine
finally all excess members get all of
the benefits of our other membership
tiers you get the add free website
experience access to our live broadcast
and show library access to the shows
mailbags the full three hours of the ben
shapiro show along with the dedicated
editorials from law so head on over to
daily we're calm slash subscribe join
all access get 15% off with coupon code
Shapiro right now that is daily wire.com
slash subscribe we will see you there
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
you
so there was a time when in the
aftermath of pandemic everybody thought
that intersectionality was gonna go the
way of the dodo bird that the entire
attempt to divide Americans by race sex
class and to try to suggest in America
is just hierarchies of power that was
gonna go by the wayside as we all face
down extraordinarily dangerous disease
and we all locked down and we all became
Americans together so that lasted
approximately 20 7.2 seconds I was
really exciting now
there's an attempt by the media to take
the racialized narrative and draw it
into kovat I've been talking about this
for a while this attempt to suggest in
America is deeply an interminably racist
because black people are dying at a
higher rate than white people from kovat
19 neglecting to mention the confounding
factors like obesity and diabetes rates
neglecting to mention the possibility
the vitamin D consumption might have
something to do with this that's
according to a study from The Lancet
neglecting to mention that there is a
vast disparity between black and white
death in Britain like four to one so
that an American brand racism that's
causing that's asperity cuz that's over
in the UK we've seen similar stuff with
regard to maternal mortality rates the
16:19 project suggested the black woman
died in childbirth a lot more than white
womens died in childbirth because of
racism there's virtually no evidence to
support the idea that the racism is the
is the deciding factor the doctors are
being like oh look a black lady gonna
let her die or vomit or low birth weight
for children that it has anything to do
with racism so instead you basically
have to say history was full of racism
we are part of history therefore this is
because of racism so now we're trying to
do that with kovin 19 there's an article
in The New York Times today it's a study
of Louisiana hospitals highlights the
pandemics disproportionate burden on
communities of color the hospital system
ochsner health serves a predominantly
white population but most patients
hospitalized with Cova 19 over a recent
six-week period were black according to
research published on Wednesday in the
New England Journal of Medicine Ochsner
health operates hospitals and outpatient
facilities throughout Louisiana about
30% of the patient population is black
among the 1382 patients with Cove and 19
hospitalized from March 1st April 11th
77% were black black patients made up
80% of patients transferred to the ICU
and nearly 82% of those put on prevents
leaders to help with breathing I have a
question are they only being put on
ventilators and in the ICU because they
are black or is it possible that maybe
people are coming in because they aren't
healthy and also happened to be black
and also if you're gonna talk about
racism the medical system wouldn't be
better indicator B that
black people are dying out of the
hospital and not being given care right
that would be an indicator of racism not
that people are getting the care that
they are supposed to need the authors of
the new study reported that compared
with white patients who were
hospitalized black patients had higher
rates of obesity diabetes high blood
pressure and chronic kidney disease well
maybe that would be the factor here
would it not maybe that would be the
factor but in the attempt to racialized
everything we have decided that kovat 19
is also racist or that it just merely
exposes an underlying American racism
again all of this is terrible for the
country when because we all Cree racism
is bad we all agree police brutality is
bad we all agree that racism should be
fought at every turn and any attempts to
suggest the black Americans are under
threat by America broadly Brit is just a
lie and it's a nasty disgusting lie at
that at something to compute guilt to
people who are not guilty of things
attempting to impede a guilt that
America has spent generations attempting
to alleviate just really really bad
stuff okay meanwhile the President of
the United States is talking about an
executive order that would crack down on
Twitter today this this has been driven
by the fact that Twitter has put fact
checks on some of his tweets now should
Twitter do that no it's incredibly
stupid
the reason it's incredibly stupid is
because Twitter is not good at
fact-checking
in fact Twitter's first fact check of
President Trump was not correct they
suggested that there is no fraud and
mail and voting not true and the fact is
that Twitter should not consider itself
to be the arbiter of truth Mark
Zuckerberg has been raked over the coals
my people right left and center Mark
Zuckerberg has perspective on free
speech and the role of these websites is
far far far better and far more
intellectually coherent than anything
Jack Dorsey that dumb ass over at
Twitter is doing here is Mark Zuckerberg
treating all big tech like that exactly
the same is not accurate here's
Zuckerberg on Dana Perino Show yesterday
saying listen we're not the arbiters of
truth people have the ability to
actually fact check things themselves
different policy I think than Twitter on
this you know I just believe strongly
that that Facebook shouldn't be the
arbiter of truth of everything that
people say online I think in general
private companies probably shouldn't be
or especially these platform companies
shouldn't be in the position of doing
that and he of course is exactly right
who's ranked over the close by the left
for this how dare he
how dare he suggest that it's not
Facebook's job
to determine absolute truth we need Jack
Dorsey doing it according to the left
well this is driven a reaction from
President Trump which is okay well then
I'm just gonna crack down on social
media now this is based on a
misinterpretation of the Communications
Decency Act section 230 so section 230
basically shields companies from
liability if they have comment sections
that's all this is so daily wire is
responsible for the people that we pay
and the people that we edit we are not
responsible for the comment sections
that does not mean we can't curate our
comment sections in fact we can carry
our comment sections section 230 of the
Communications Decency Act was
specifically created in order to protect
companies who are attempting to shield
people from viewing pornography in the
comments
sheíll people from viewing obscenity in
the comments the basic idea was why
should it be that if you police your
comments for the f-word that you will be
held liable if there's a bad comment but
if you don't please your comments then
you won't be held liable
so the Communications Decency Act
section 230 which shields companies like
Facebook and Twitter quote/unquote open
platforms that are still that are still
curated in terms of the commentary or
edited that shield those from from
liability the original idea was that the
two alternatives should not be either
you are fully liable for all your
comments or you have to have a
completely unregulated comment section
right that's why the the provision was
created in the first place people have
misread that to believe that Twitter has
violated section 230 by not being
unbiased or something and that's not
true Twitter doesn't have to be unbiased
that's clear from the language does that
mean the Twitter is smart no Twitter is
incredibly stupid but I would just
recommend that people recognize that you
know who's in favor of rewriting section
230 the way the president Trump is
talking about Joe Biden like Joe Biden
literally came out a couple months ago
and said that he would like to rewrite
section 230 he said it should be revoked
immediately why because it's in them
because Facebook isn't merely an
Internet company he just wants to
control Facebook that is that is not a
that that is not a good thing for
conservatives the notion that if you are
going to regulate YouTube or Google or
Facebook or Twitter and this is somehow
going to renounce a conservative benefit
I have some questions on how exactly you
believe that's going to go when
Elizabeth Warren is in charge of
regulating the Facebook or Twitter like
listen I think Twitter's a garbage heap
- it's a flaming dumpster fire I've
talked about it extensively over the
last several weeks but the the idea that
you're somehow going to be able to
regulate this from the top of
with some sort of executive order that
is that is a bizarre take a very very
bizarre take now some conservatives have
been suggesting that we need to rewrite
the Communications Decency Act because
the because effectively when you edit
these comments enough you are acting as
a publisher you're basically
distinguishing between things that you
think are okay to be up and things that
you think are not okay to be up but the
CDA specifically provides for that sort
of thing and people should recognize
that the actual result of this is going
to be not that Twitter becomes a fully
open platform in which everybody gets to
publish whatever they want but to shut
down or Twitter right and people should
recognize that will shut down our
comment sections a Daily wire we don't
have time to curate all your comments so
we'll just shut down our comment section
every comment section across the country
will die if you get rid of section 230
so recognize that not every problem has
a great government solution and this
would be one of those I think Twitter is
handled horribly too I think that an
executive order against social media
companies on the basis that Trump
doesn't like Twitter is a is a very
large-scale mistake the expansion of
size and scope of government is not when
is the last time this is redounded to
the benefit of Americans seriously it
just it just doesn't or conservatives
more broadly
alrighty time for a bunch of things that
I hate all righty so we are watching
actual world historical events happening
in real time Hong Kong has now lost
complete autonomy according to the
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo Hong Kong
is no longer an autonomous government
the New York Times reports that
Secretary of State Pompeo announced on
Wednesday the State Department no longer
considered Hong Kong to have significant
autonomy under Chinese rule a move that
indicated the Trump administration was
likely to and some or all of the US
government's special trade economic
relations with the territory in southern
China this is a major story there are
many many American companies that have
bases in Hong Kong that have branches in
Hong Kong because Hong Kong still had
some level of independence from the
Chinese government the Chinese
government has been using the pandemic
firstly unleashes the pandemic on the
world then they decide you know what
it's a great time to crack down on all
dissent inside Hong Kong and it's
precisely what they have been doing they
have now pushed legislation that would
make it treason to criticize the Chinese
government that is the that is the next
move that the Chinese government has
been pursuing this is really horrifying
stuff and it demonstrates full scale
that when you
when you run away from dictatorships
dictatorships don't treat you nicely
when the British decided to cede control
of Hong Kong to the Chinese government
in the name of local control back in
1997 there were a bunch of provisions
that were supposed to protect the
autonomy of Hong Kong all of them have
been ignored by the Chinese governments
and nobody was able to do anything
because once you leave you can't go back
it sound like the British were gonna
reinvade Hong Kong none of that was
going to happen and for China the
possibility of controlling hong kong and
then waiting for a friendly
administration in the EU waiting for our
friendly administration in the United
States it's a pretty rich it's a pretty
rich thing right I mean okay so we'll
take a hit for a couple years for a
commie country we have a billion
citizens who we can simply exploit so
all right we'll take the short-term hit
in order to take control of the lives of
millions of people in Hong Kong
China's legislature has now approved a
proposal according to CNN to impose a
highly contentious national security law
in Hong Kong an unprecedented move
critics say threatens fundamental
political freedoms in civil liberties in
Hong Kong by the way if people can get
out of Hong Kong they are leaving on
mass right now watch for the wave it's
gonna be incredible the country's rubber
stamp Parliament the National People's
Congress nearly unanimously approved the
resolution on Thursday to introduce the
sweeping security legislation it bans
secession subversion of state power
terrorism foreign intervention and
allows mainland China's of state
security agencies to operate in the city
that is full-on communist party control
of Hong Kong the law drastically
broadens Beijing power over Hong Kong
which lasted was roiled by
anti-government protests calling for
greater democracy and more autonomy from
mainland China protesters took to the
streets and clashed with police the
approval of the laws expected to result
in more demonstrations but nobody is
actually expecting that the the blowback
from the world is gonna stop the Chinese
government Mike Pompeo denounced the law
as a disastrous decision the latest in a
series of actions that fundamentally
undermine Hong Kong's autonomy and
freedoms he says no reasonable person
can sir today that hong kong maintains a
high degree of autonomy from china given
facts on the ground under the hong kong
human rights and democracy act the US
government has to annually verify to
Congress the city remains autonomous
from China or at risks losing a special
status with the United States it's about
to lose all of its status from the
United States there may be visa
sanctions economic sanctions against the
Chinese there could be an end to
the extradition treaty that exists
between the US and Hong Kong and the
Chinese government has yet to respond to
the United States but they say this is
China's internal affair because it turns
out that when China says you know to two
countries one China whether they say
about Taiwan or whether they say about
Hong Kong what they actually mean is we
are going to control this thing in
top-down fashion and kill all of our
opponents because communism is evil and
remains evil president Trump's foreign
policy aides are discussing actions
according to the New York Times that
would be among the harshest punishment
is taken against China over the past
three years these could have
far-reaching consequences for the 7.5
million Hong Kong residents Hong Kong
has been a financial and commercial hub
since late last century many Chinese and
foreign firms use Hong Kong as an
international or regional base and a lot
of elite Communist Party members do
business and own property there Pompeyo
says the security was a death knell for
Hong Kong's freedom the the United
Nations is is going to do nothing
because of course China sits on the own
Security Council demonstrating full
scale that the UN is a wretched hive of
scum and villainy it is a garbage
institution run by some of the worst
countries on earth the the president is
is looking not to get into a serious
conflict with China but from said that
we are going to give a very powerful
response presumably we're gonna break
off cooperation with trade and law
enforcement so your prices at the market
are gonna go up but honestly we never
should have opened China in the first
place
good case we made that we should have
simply let them collapse the same way
the Soviet Union collapsed and we just
put it off for 40 years but there's been
a long time coming and the West looked
the other way when she's like with North
Korea the West looked the other way and
looked the other way and look the other
way until Hong Kong became a slave state
to the Chinese government once again
this has been going on for years in the
the in 2002 the Hong Kong government
introduced its first proposal under
article 23 of the basic law that
authorized the local administration to
pass laws covering treason and Sedition
ok the Regina it was the then Security
Secretary she was a proponent of the
bill she she pledged in 2017 to enact
article 23 and suitable measures so five
years literally five years removed from
the Hong Kong treaty China was already
trying to institute full security
control over Hong Kong so it's just it
took
but Hong Kong has now become again a
it's tragic I mean what we're watching
right now is absolute tragedy and again
demonstrative of the idea the one in the
United States when the EU when liberal
powers leave those spaces are filled by
other people power politics abhors a
vacuum and China was was always going to
be checked only by the willingness to to
utilize American power and I talking
military power I'm talking economic
power and all other elements to protect
people but apparently they're they're
not going to I had serious doubts that
that any action is gonna be taken by the
EU in coordination with the United
States here okay time for some other
things that I hate so andrew Cuomo is a
flaming dumpster fire of a governor it's
an awful awful governor so Andrew Cuomo
continues to preside over a state that
had the worst outcomes from Cove in
nineteen he continues to clash with
Mayor Bill DeBlasio they still can't
decide on a unified policy he continues
to sort of futz his way through this
thing but because he's on TV a lot then
he has very high popularity ratings and
now he's gonna blame everybody else for
his own stupid leadership
so yesterday Andrew Cuomo was asked
about the fact that a huge percentage of
New Yorkers have died in nursing homes
now New York is lying about this because
when New York does when you talk about
undercounting when New York does is if
you are from a nursing home and you get
Kovan 19 then they actually suggest that
you are not from a nursing home if you
die in a hospital so you get coma 19
you're at a nursing home you're shipped
to a hospital you die in the hospital
New York does not count that as a
nursing home death but you obtained it
at the nursing home so it's a nursing
home death but New York doesn't say that
so they've been dramatically under
Counting nursing home deaths as we all
know for months only relieved in like
the last couple of weeks New York had
policy and the policy was that nursing
homes were forced by law to reaccept
people with Kovan 19 here is Andrew
Cuomo yesterday blaming the nursing
homes themselves for a law that he
himself had promulgated the obligation
is on the nursing home to say I can't
take a covert positive person I'm too
crowded I'm too busy I don't have enough
PPE whatever the answer is doesn't even
matter
it's if they say I can't take the person
they can't take the person um I'm sorry
you are you are the world's worst
governor and blaming everybody else for
the fact that you are awful is pretty
amazing
meanwhile that's not where Cuomo stop so
Cuomo is now looking
he basically he's the handout governor
all right that's what he is he
I need ventilators president Trump make
it happen I need PPE president Trump
make it happen
now I need money federal government make
it happen maybe it's because you guys
are running like hundreds of billions of
dollars in debt because you've been
passing crappy fiscal policy for decades
on end maybe that would be your big
problem so Cuomo yesterday he said
there's no national recovery without a
federal government bailout or
alternatively you could take austerity
measures that you always should have
taken instead of signing garbage
contracts with your local unions here
was heroes Andrew Cuomo blaming the
federal government again it's very easy
con it's got to be easy to be a Democrat
all you got to do is blame the
Republican president for everything on
earth and the media just goes right
along with it this dude has an 80%
approval rating and his he is presided
over what one quarter of all deaths in
America from covin 19 you want to talk
about trumping a crappy president
because 100,000 people have died
how'd the fact that this dumbass was
shipping old people back to nursing
homes with Kovan 19 not disinfecting the
subways not shutting down the subways
and then whining about the fact that he
wasn't doing his job in getting
resources for his own state somehow
governor Gavin Newsom here in California
got resources for the state here was the
Andrew Cuomo blaming the federal
government again states are doing
reopening states are responsible for
testing states are responsible for
tracing states are responsible for the
health care system states are
responsible for the enforcement of all
the procedures around reopening but at
the same time the federal government has
a role to play and the federal
government has to do its part as we work
our way through this crisis and they
cannot be a national recovery if the
state and local governments are not
funded that is a fact
um no it actually can be a national
recovery if the state and local
governments acted responsibly in the
first place you blew out the credit card
then you had an unforeseen expense and
now you're blaming people for not
filling in the part of the part of the
bill that you incurred in the first
place Cuomo wouldn't let this one go
ready said its own American not to
bailout the states on American or bad
American if you don't feel like we
should pay in if we should fill in all
of the pension gaps in Andrew Cuomo's
crappy budget you have people saying
well we don't want to pass a bill that
helps
kradic states it would be a blue state
bailout is what some have said Senator
McConnell stopping blue state bailouts
this is really an ugly ugly sentiment it
is an on American response we're still
the United States of America those words
meant something yeah they didn't mean
that the federal government was supposed
to fill in your crappy governance by the
way it's hilarious to me so it's an ugly
unamerican response to say it's a blue
state bailout weird because five seconds
ago you were implying that the net
recipients of tax benefits were people
in red states literally he said that
like four weeks ago but this guy is he's
the worst governor he's a terrible
governor III am enjoying the I am
enjoying states rights andrew Cuomo cuz
states right Andrew Cuomo is at war with
I want the federal government to do
everything with me at for me Andrew
Cuomo so at the same time that he's
saying I have authority to run my state
bill de blasio doesn't have authority
Donald Trump doesn't have authority he's
saying daddy Trump please fill in please
give me my allowance I want my allowance
right now so at the same time he's
saying there's no nation without the
states he is suggesting that it's the
job of the nations who fill in the
states you can't have it both ways you
want to be treated as an autonomous
being or would you prefer to be treated
as a dependent pick because you don't
have that you don't get it both ways
here was Andrew Cuomo trying to have it
both ways
state government state economies local
economies that's what the national
economy is made of what is the national
economy but for a function of the states
there is no nation without the states
they tend to forget that in this town
but it's the obvious fact there's no
nation without the state's okay so
you're gonna have to explain to me how
the nation is then suppose if there's no
nation without the states and the nation
is refusing to recognize your state then
why does the nation have money like
really that's a question then the money
isn't funneled through the states the
money is taken directly from citizens
the nation does exist in the absence of
the states at this point thanks to a
federal bureaucracy built up over the
course of the last hundred twenty years
but with
that said it also happens to be the case
but the job of the federal government
was not created to bail out the state
from their bad financial decision-making
how this guy isn't like what happened to
New Yorkers hello McFly hello how are
you guys how do you guys think this
guy's good governor hell I'm very very
confused just cuz the last name is Kwan
I'm so sick of political families in the
United States like it's very very
tiresome
all right so New York well done you've
selected the world's greatest governor
okay well I think we've run out of time
for things that I like tomorrow is a
Jewish holiday so I will be back here on
Monday please try not to wreck America
further people if we could just like cut
it out that'd be amazing I also have two
additional hours of content coming up
later today you can subscribe you can
get all of that a little bit later today
over at daily wire.com and we will see
you then or we'll see you here next week
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling assistant director Pavel
I douse key technical producer Austin
Stevens playback and media operated by
Nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam SIA vets audio is
mixed by micro Romina hair and makeup is
by Nika Geneva the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 25 hey everybody its Andrew
Clavin host of the Andrew Clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the American Republic is
collapsing the end of days is
approaching and the moon is turned to
blood but on the Andrew Clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over the Andrew Clavin show
and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]